vous êtes 26 ans 26 ans et pratique en
1988 il s'agit du premier passage
télévisé de marc levy à l'époque il
n'est pas encore l'auteur à succès des
années 2000 mais un jeune chef
d'entreprise
sa société logitech france est
spécialisée dans l'informatique
nous avons pris paris de développer nous
mêmes des ordinateurs en europe
l'aventuré se termine en 1989 deux ans
plus tard il fonde un cabinet
d'architecturé
mais sa vraie passion c'est l'écriture
en 2000 à presque 40 ans il sort son
premier livre
et si c'était vrai avant même sa
parution et droits d'adaptation sont
achetés par steven spielberg
tous les studios que ça soit 19,1 mode
colombière dreamworks appelé tout le
monde
contre toute attente son roman devient
un best-seller et ses autres livres
rencontreront le même succès en 2008
marc levy déménage à new york la ville
servira de décor dans plusieurs de ses
romans et parfois je me rapproche
tellement de mes personnages que je
finis par croire qu'ils existent
vraiment et voilà ça c'est serré maison
de giulia qui est qui m'a embauché menu
plein de fois pendant que j'écrivais ce
roman et je m'installais en bas de cette
maison est
et j'imaginais ses mouvements ses
sorties en 2010 l'auteur passe la barre
des 10 8 millions d'exemplaires vendus
dans le monde
cette même année son 11e livre paraît le
voleur d'ombrés
la recette reste la même une bonne
intrigue une dose de surnaturel et une
écriture cinématographique à la fin les
lecteurs sont conquis marc levy ça passe
de de la simplicité à l'extraordinaire
au fantastique et ça nous permet en même
temps par une simple lecture de se créer
un monde tout à fait extraordinaire
aujourd'hui marc levy l'auteur français
vivant le plus lu dans le monde
en vingt ans il a vendu plus de 50
millions d'exemplaires traduits en 49
langues
[Musique]